problem number one problem number one
say they give us a series 26 1430 and
they say and the sequence above the
first term is to each number after the
first obtained by adding one to the
preceding number and then doubling the
results so you add one so you get three
and then you double it you get six you
add one to six to seven right this is
plus one and then you multiply it by two
ND at seven times two is 14 14 plus one
is 15 times two is 30 and they want the
sixth term so then 30 plus one is 31
times two is 62 and then you add one
right we add one first so you to 63 and
then you multiply that times two that's
what 126 so that is choice e problem too
if a a times X plus y is equal to 45 and
ax is equal to 15 what is a y equal so
let's just distribute this a-here you
get ax plus a y is equal to 45 they tell
us ax is equal to 15 right so that is
equal to 15 ax is equal to 15 so you get
15 plus a y is equal to 45 subtract 15
from both sides you get a y is equal to
30 that's our answer they want to know
what a why is you don't just solve for a
or why just a why so that's choice C
next problem okay before drawing this
let me read it so I can figure out what
I have to draw on the speedometer above
what is the speed in miles per hour
indicated by the needle position okay so
they let me see if I can draw this so
it's they give one the firt at the
bottom one like that that's given in
feet per second feet per second and then
the next one up is this one that's miles
per hour miles per hour
and then the top one is km/h I'm going
to write it on this side although they
write it up here km/h and then they
indicate and on the miles per hour thing
on the miles per hour I guess I know you
would actually call this measurement or
so there's 30 and then there's 1 / 2 / 3
/ and then they go to 60 all right and
then the line they draw is right here
goes like that it was like that and they
say in this pedometer above what is the
speed in miles per hour indicated by the
needle position and the reason why I
didn't draw that up you know I didn't do
much detail on this line or on this line
is because this one's km/h this one's
feet per second so I don't care about
those I just care about the miles per
hour and that is this one and let's see
they drew it here so how big is each of
these slashes you see one two three four
so this is each of these go 14 to the
distance between 30 and 60 right each of
them go one fourth of the distance so
you could say for example this is
halfway between 30 and 60 so this is
going to be 45 all right and so what's
halfway between 30 and 45 which is where
the thing is well 45 is 15 more than 30
so there's going to be seven and a half
more than 30 so this point right here is
going to be 37.5 and how did I know that
you could either say well if i just take
30 divided by four one two three four
each of these are going to be 7.5 right
30 divided by 4 is equal to 7.5 or you
could say well this middle one is
definitely gonna be 45 because 45 is
right in between 30 and 60 and then
what's right in between 30 and 45 well
that's 37.5 again so the speedometer is
indicating 37.5 miles per hour that's
choice B next problem problem for how
many different positive three digit
integers can be formed if the three
digits four five and six must be used in
each of the integers
in each of the integers okay so they're
saying that I mean they're essentially
saying how many combinations can you get
of the number 456 so the way i could
write out all of the combinations if you
like I mean you could write for 5 64 65
right those are the all of the ones that
if you have four in front then if you
have five in front you have 5 for 6 or
you can have 5 64 I just switched them
and then if you have six in front you
can have six four six four five or six
five four so those are six the other way
I can I think about is I have three
numbers right I can put one of three in
the first position I can put one of two
in the second position and then I would
have one left over in the last position
right I'd have three choices to put in
the first number four five or six then
after I put one in that first position I
have two left so there's two more
possibilities and then I have one left
over for the third position so you could
also think of it this way you could just
write them out one two three four five
six numbers or you could use that ladder
technique i just talked about and then
be three times two times one which is
also equal to six next problem we draw
what they have drawn so it's a triangle
probably bitter off well I'll try my
best then there's a line it goes like
this goes like this
and then there's dotted lines maître see
if I can do that dotted lines the hard
part of these problems is drawing them I
think you have to do that on the NCT
okay they do the three-dimensional
figure represented above consist of
rectangular and triangle faces fair
enough triangular faces each rectangular
face has area are so this is a
rectangular face here there's three
rectangular faces right so a rectangular
air area of the rectangle is equal to R
and each triangular faces area tissot
area of each of the triangle is equal to
T what is the total surface area of the
figure in terms of RT so how many
rectangular surfaces are there well
there's there's this one in back right
there's this one in the back that's a
kind of behind the thing you have this
base that I'll draw in magenta right
this is the base rectangular surface and
then you have this one that's closest to
us right which I could you know this one
on that's the closest so you have three
rectangular surfaces so it's three times
R because each rectangular surface has
an area of our and then how many of the
triangular surfaces do you have you have
the one in the back back here and then
you have the one in the front right here
alright so you have two triangular
surfaces so it's three times the
rectangular areas plus 2 times the
triangular areas because there's two
triangular so 3 R plus 2t and that's
choice B next problem problem 6 if n is
a positive integer and n plus 1 over 2
to the N is equal to one half n equals n
equals what all right so let's think
about how how we can do this let's
multiply let's multiply both sides of
this equation by 2 to the N so if you
multiply both sides equation x 2 to the
N you get n plus 1 is equal to one-half
x 2 to the N let me think about this a
little bit if c1 halftime to the N one
half is the same thing as 2 to the
negative 1 right 2 to the negative 1 so
this is n plus 1 is equal to n plus 1
let me think about this n plus 1 is
equal to is equal to 2 to the negative 1
times 2 to the n so n plus 1 is equal to
22 sorry 2 to the N minus 1 huh so
that's where i can get it really at this
point the best thing i can think of is
just trying out the choice is to see
which one works if you look at choice a1
and we actually let's just we could just
do it from the original and that's
faster 1 plus 1 over 2 to the N is equal
to 2 over 2 to the 1 which is equal to
one so it's not one half so it's not a
equals one choice b is 2 so be 2 plus 1
which is 3 over 2 squared over 2 squared
which equals three fourths so that's not
the answer and if you look at choice C
choice C is 3 so 3 plus 1 is 4 over 2 to
the 3rd 2 to the third that's for over 8
2 equals one-half so it's choice C and
I'm trying to figure out if there's a
way that you could solve for that easier
other than trying out the numbers but
for some reason it's not popping into my
head let me know a message if it if you
figure it out but I also do these under
time pressure but I will see you in the
next video